en cette journée noire annoncées dans
les transports parisiens ce vendredi la
circulation du métro de la capitale sera
fortement perturbé en raison d'un
mouvement de grève des employés de la
ratp
ils réclament une hausse de leurs
salaires pour en parler on retrouve en
direct notre reporter guimard aussi
egima bonjour vous trouvez à
fontenay-sous-bois les usagers de la
ratp vont devoir s'armer de courage
aujourd'hui
oui tout à fait à doha s'il est bien une
journée où il fallait éviter les
transports le public parisien s'était
bien aujourd'hui jouent deux journées
noires vous avez employé le mot qui
convient à huit lignes de métro
totalement fermée et les lignes 3 4 à 6
7 9 et 13 ne fonctionneront cause heures
de pointe est encore à un rythme réduit
un train sur deux seulement pas de
problème en revanche du côté des lignes
automatiques une et 14 les lignes de rer
a et b seront elles également très
perturbé un train sur deux aux heures de
pointe un train sur trois en heures
creuses les lignes c et d ne devrait pas
être impactée enfin il ne devrait avoir
qu'un tramway sur trois seulement et une
ligne de bus sur deux selon les secteurs
de la capitale l argument que réclame
exactement les salariés de la ratp
eh bien vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
doha il s'agit essentiellement
aujourd'hui de demander une
revalorisation de salaire en tout cas
une revalorisation plus importante que
celle proposée par la direction de la
ratp cette dernière a mis sur la table
2,7 pour cent d'augmentation mais selon
les syndicats la hausse qui s'applique à
l'ensemble des salariés de la ratp n'est
que de 0,4 pour cent c'est à dire bien
loin des 3 % d'inflation prévu par
l'insee au premier semestre 3 % de plus
c'est donc le minimum demandé par les
syndicats une séance de négociation doit
avoir lieu aujourd'hui une journée qui
s'annonce donc compliquée pour les
usagers comme pour la direction de la
ratp à guy marosi merci pour toutes ces
précisions en direct de fontenay sous
bois